So one you still can't do in the Conference Central application is that you
can't get the conferences that you have
registered to attend. So now you're going to
go ahead and add that functionality. You're going to be implementing the
getConferencesToAttend method, which is going to return a collection.
Of all the conferences that the user has registered
to attend. This list will continue to include conferences
that they've actually already attended, so it's not just
the ones that they will attend but the ones
that they registered to attend. You're going to work with the
skeleton implementation of get conferences to attend. You can
find this skeleton definition in the same file where you
found the skeleton definition for register for conference. So
you're going to go ahead and add the getConferencesToAttend method to
Conference API and then you can implement the to do's. So
as usual if the users null throw an authorization exception because
we do need to know the user if we don't know
who the person is then how can we find the Conferences
that they want to go to. And then you're going to
get the profile for the user. And again if the profile
doesn't exist, got to throw another error. And then here's where
you're going to do the real work. You're going to get
a lit of the strings of the keys to attend, then you're going to have to iterate
over that list and turn every keyString into
an actual key, and then, you're going to have to
load conferences for the keys and of course
return the list of conferences. All right. So the
first thing to do is to add the
skeleton implementation of get conferences to attend to the
conference API. And then, go ahead and fill
in the to do's, to implement the function.
So one more thing you might need to
know, is that you can use ofy().load().keys, pass in
a keysList, and then call a .values() to
load the entities once you have a list of
their keys. So go ahead and implement the
getConferencesToAttend() method now. Then I have a question for
you: why can't you just return the
value of the profile's conference keys to attend
property? After all, we have this property,
conference keys to attend, so why can't get
conferences to attend? Just simply return conference
keys to attend. Is it because the profile
stores conferences names, not keys? Or is it
because the profile stores conference keys as strings?
Or in fact you actually could do it, it's just a less efficient way to do it.